in order for capitalism to work you need
four elements there are four elements to
capitalism for it to work and what
america has done is
america's taken one of these elements
out
and it's only left three of them here's
what the three are
capitalism allows you and i the freedom
to buy
whatever we want to buy that's legal so
freedom to buy
freedom to sell whatever you want that's
legal and freedom to try
you want to try real estate it didn't
work great i want to go
you want to try opening up a restaurant
great didn't work you want to go try
this food you want to go try this
you have the freedom to try whatever you
want to try that's legal right that's
the freedom
that you have the last one is the most
important one
has been taken away and i'll get to the
last one here in a minute look
this last week the last four days i've
flown 24 of our executives to jekyll
island
the reason why i chose jekyll island is
because in i think november 10th of uh
uh 1910 i think 110 years ago
uh a group of leaders led by senator
senator
aldridge got together at jekyll island
and they started the federal reserve and
we went in the room where federal
reserve got started with these six
different bankers and
senators and power players that were
there and they made this idea which
eventually became
the federal reserve 1913 and it turned
into what it is today that printed
trillions of dollars
some say it's the most evil thing that's
been built some said we needed that at a
time like that because of what happened
at war
regardless of what it is we went to
jekyll island and what jekyll island was
known for
is where rockefellers had their own
compound william rockefeller we took our
guys we got a private tour
of the rockefeller compound jp morgan
chase matter of fact
alexander graham bill made the first
phone call to anybody
from jekyll island just so you know
that's the idea of jekyll it's a very
exclusive type of a club many years ago
so we had this meeting
while we're at the meeting i unpacked
because we were writing the constitution
of our company the declaration
of our um values and principles and we
started at seven o'clock
one night we went to 3 30 in the morning
great experience one of the moments we
talked about capitalism
and when i explained capitalism i said
one thing about great leaders
and great parents is when you see
as a parent i have an eight-year-old son
a seven-year-old son today and a
four-year-old daughter today right
it's very hard to see your kids
you can do everything for your kids and
when you want to do everything for your
kids
it's very hard to not do it because you
have the resources to do it right
so where am i going with this many times
i was 22 years old
i was in that 49 000 i went to my dad
and i said dad i need you to pay off my
debt i'm in debt it's really bad i'm in
a bad situation my credit score is 484
495 499.
and my dad said son i'm going to do one
of the best things that i'm going to do
for you today
that you'll thank me decades from that
so what's that he says
i'm not going to pay off your debt i
said what do you mean he says
said what are thomas that's the best
thing you're going to do for me what
kind of a father are you
all my friends that i told this story to
you know like oh dude my dad
helped me out my mom helped me out they
built me out all the time all my friends
got bailed out
except one kid doesn't get bailed out
and it's me
my dad decides to not bail me out like
how do you not pay
pay off my do you're my daddy you're
supposed to do this he says i'm not
supposed to do this you're a grown man
now
you got to be able to figure this thing
i said and by the way here's the thing
i said what's that my friend at the time
introduced me to a bankruptcy attorney
says pat
here go file bankruptcy you know what he
said here's what he said
he said how much more credit cards you
got left that's i said i got about seven
thousand dollars
he said don't follow because unless you
spend all the other seven thousand
dollars some of you guys may have
this story go spend it then file the bk
because at that point
don't worry about it the laws allows us
to but go spend all the seven thousand
dollars
so one of my friends told me you know my
dad told me he said if you file a bk for
the rest of your life you're gonna take
the easy way out it'll be one of the
worst things you'll ever do if you do it
and i'm telling you i'm not paying you
off
but i think you can figure out a way to
pay this money back for two weeks i
didn't talk to my dad
you don't end up happening i kept every
single statement if you've ever seen a
movie the video life of an entrepreneur
in 90 seconds
if you ever watch that video go back and
watch it it's 90 seconds
if you see the credit report pause and
look at it
that's my credit score that's actually
my
credit report i ran in 2004
i think it's november date when i ran it
it shows my credit score 484 495 499.
i was broke my dad didn't pay me up i
kept
every single statement you know how
crazy my credit report
score was i forgot to return time
warner's little
uh uh uh you know uh i don't know what
road runner thing they had back in the
days the cable box i don't return it
i owe time warner 720 i'm like to take
this down
road runner back i had 720 i had to pay
them
at 49 000 my dad didn't bail me out you
know what happened next couple years
i paid every single thing that i had i
paid it off
what it did to me was the following
remember the freedom to buy freedom to
sell freedom to try
you know what the last one is that my
dad allowed to happen which is why he
raised this
leader that he raised because without
him i'm a different boy
there is no patrick bait david what my
dad did to me that day you know what it
was
it's the freedom to fail it's the
hardest one
my dad says i'm comfortable with you
failing
even though deep down inside he was in
pain wanting to bail out
his only son what father doesn't want to
bail out the sun
he said i'm not going to bail you out
and that exact
exact thing that happened to me made me
realize for the rest of my life
i can stand on my own two feet so what's
going on with america tonight and what
does it have to do with jekyll island
and jekyll island i was talking to my
leaders i said the moment a leader
realizes you do your part you lead your
guys you work for you guys
you go out you create a great
opportunity you create an environment
where people are excited i have a leader
like you
but the moment you're afraid of your
sales guys
being rejected and you feel guilty about
the price they have to pay
you are no longer a leader because you
can't sit there and feel guilty
try to take that freedom to fail away
from them you know what america is doing
right now today
hear what america is doing right now
america is afraid of americans failing
america is afraid of people failing i'm
not talking covert 19 by the way
i'm not talking cover 19 because this is
a different time
america chose to change the guidelines
about the fact that you can't open up
the restaurant
if you're shutting down my restaurant
and i want to work that's on you
government not on me i don't want to
close down my restaurant you did so you
do have to do something about those
times
i'm talking set cover decide because
this is an anomaly but
the whole too big to fail 2008 that's
the government's mistake
they keep the rates low nina nina no
income no assets no income no assets
and then a woman gets greedy you got to
let them fail you know who bought them
chase final for 1.9 billion but didn't
do with other companies
today in america we have so many people
that are becoming entitled we have so
many people
that have this victim mentality we have
so many people that want to say it's the
government's fault
we have so many people that want the
government to bail them out we have so
many people that want everybody to do
everything for them why
because when it comes on to capitals we
don't have capitalism today in america
and not because oh we're a socialistic
society we don't have capitalism today
because we're not allowing people to
fail
we are afraid of people failing by the
way
this applies in the way you run a
country this applies in the way you
raise a family
this applies in the way you run a
company
you gotta allow people to fail everybody
has to have the ability to fail because
when you fail
you when you feel painful embarrassing
publicly humiliating sometimes when you
fail
that is a moment where everybody in the
world is kind of watching to see what
you really are made up of because that's
what we cannot measure we can measure a
lot of different things
your body fat your height your weight
your shoe size your hat size
everything we can measure we can't
measure your fight deep down inside and
capitalism forces
the world to find out if you got the
ability to recover
and recoup and come back and redeem
yourself after
you failed because we allowed you to
fail so there is a certain opportunity
and failing
so going back to you how are you
when you fail did your family let you
fail were you bailed out all the time
does your company let you fill are you
always like oh my gosh you know what
don't worry about it honey
you're tired go home early because you
got to get some rest sweetheart
oh my they said no to you shame on these
customers
they don't even know who they have on
working with somebody like you
or the country oh poor you i understand
you you are really going through tough
times people don't understand here you
go let me give you some unemployment
check for a long time two years
it's gonna be all right we got your back
that's not having my back
that's taken away my ability to find out
what my dog fight what my dog fight
looks like
the moment you find out your dog fight
you have no idea what great things can
happen in your life so having said that
the next time somebody tries to bail you
out
take that as a form of somebody feeling
guilty for you losing and if you can
even stand up to your own self and say
you know what i don't need that handout
i don't need to bail out
if you can do that you're at the
ultimate level if you don't take the
bail out because you're in a league of
your
own because very few people can do that
in a moment
look i would have taken my that bill on
me i'm telling you right i'm not sitting
here telling you i'm
walk on water my dad didn't let me
be bailed out and look what happened to
leadership so this applies to business
society and the company family the way
you raise people the way you raise
leaders around you
you can look at this message and ask
yourself what kind of a leader you want
to build
and what kind of a leader you want to be
with that being said if you're watching
to say pat
i want i want to get tougher i want to
be able to become a stronger
leader myself and develop stronger
leaders if that's the case
watch this video i did a year ago titled
10 ways to develop stronger leaders if
you're not watching click on this
video here to get the message out of
that video with that being said
have a great week being okay
with having the freedom to buy freedom
to sell freedom to try and most
importantly
the freedom to fail